It's fan appreciation month at Screen Junkies,
and to reward our awesome fans,
we're making the Honest Trailers that YOU voted for!
Here's your #3 choice:
Based on a sneaker commercial,
comes a film that got the rights to Michael Jordan
and the Looney Tunes,
then said "Screw it".
That's all the work we're gonna put into this one."
It's money time!"
Space Jam.
Experience the Citizen Kane
of live-action, animated, hybrid
basketball movies.
Full of bright colors,
cartoon violence,
"Someone's killing someone."
And second- tier, mid-nineties NBA stars
that blew the tiny mind of every kid who saw it,
and permanently blinded them to its many many flaws.
Look millennials, I know you're just getting old enough
to feel nostalgia for the first time,
but trust me, this one sucks.
Journey to the center of the earth
where all the Looney Tunes live, apparently.
For a story about aliens
stealing the talent of basketball players,
to win a game against Bugs Bunny,
to rescue a failing amusement park
that's so lazily told.
No one even cares that Michael Jordan got kidnapped.
You think Michael's all right?
Boy, I'd hate to leave him like this.
Oh, I'm sure he's fine.
Cartoons are real.
"You know that your friends are cartoon characters?"
"Yeah, so?"
Or that Bill Murray can travel between dimensions.
"How did you get here, anyway?"
"Producer's a friend of mine.
Just had a teamster come and drop me off."
I mean, I'm not mad that he's in this,
just, try even a little bit next time?
The movie doesn't even take place in space.
It's called Space Jam!
Return to Michael Jordan's weird baseball era
that conspiracy theorists think was a
secret suspension for gambling.
"If we win, you give the NBA players their talent back.
If you win, you get me."
Hmm.
Then cringe as your childhood hero
shows off the limitations of his non-basketball skills,
like, acting:
"You're a cartoon; you're not real."
Coaching:
"Let's just go out and have fun."
Yeah!
Being a good teammate:
"Somebody steal the ball, get it to me."
Being a good friend:
"Just face it, you guys stink."
Wearing appropriate-sized khakis,
and being a role model:
"This goes against everything they
taught me in health class."
"Do you want to win or not?"
Yikes, unless you're dunking on somebody,
don't be like Mike, kids.
Cling to your fleeting innocence with all your favorite loony tunes
...or at least these bootleg sound-alikes, now that Mel Blanc is dead.
"What's up doc?"
...and rev your engines for the debut of Lola Bunny
Oh yeah...
Who gave boys a weird rabbit fetish long before Judy Hopps.
As you laugh along with all their classic cartoon hijinks,
and convieniently forget that must of this movies run-time
...is dedicated to Newman trying not to get fired.
"You're all right, you're all right!"
Thrill at one of the worst referee games in basketball,
since the ref in Airbud let a dog in the court.
"He's right, ain't no rule said the dog can't play basketball."
With dozens of flagrant fouls,
Shady score-keeping,
and a blatant disregard for solid fundamentals.
"But if you don't find a 5th player,
your team will forfeit the game."
Oh NOW you care about the rules!
Where were you when the two players in the tune-squad shot a monster in the face?!
So enjoy a 90 minute long commercial.
"Get your Hanes on,
lace up your Nike',
gran your Wheaties and your Gatorade,
and we'll pick up a Big Mac on the way to the ballpark."
That in retrospect,
only exist to sell Looney Tunes' toys,
and Air Jordans.
"Cool shoes..."
But sadly is still the best movie starring an NBA player.
"You realize who I am?
I'm your Genie!"
...Euh
Space jam 2 with Lebron it is.
Starring:
"A soundtrack that totally makes up for the mediocre movie"
"Seal's version of 'Fly Like An Eagle"
"Salt-N-Pepa"
"R.Kelly's 'I Believe I Can Fly"
"A duet between Chris Rock and Barry White"
"More R.Kelly"
"And that Quad City DJ's song, that's all
'Come on and slam
and welcome to the jam"
Y'know,
so good.
"NBA Jam
"NBA Jam, Toonament Edition"
Y'know what else is better than the movie?
The original website,
that Warner Brothers hasn't changed since 1996.
Be sure to subscribe,
for more Honest Trailers!
Thanks to Superfans:
Austin B.,
Conner M.,
and Alicia G.,
for voting for this trailer,
and making Fan Appreciation Month
that much cooler.
If you want more fan appreciation month,
click the box in the left,
to watch 5th and 4th choice Honest Trailers.
Or if you're feeling a bit odd,
click the box on the right, for
a delightfully weird interview with Vin Diesel
from "xXx Return of Xander Cage."
"I believe I can fly!
I believe I can touch the sky!"
"The entire bee movie script."
"Call Kenny Loggins,
'cause you're in the danger zone."
"Goishey sloishey."
"You're not my brother!
You're just a pet who grew legs!"
"He's got you in shrekmate,
it's all ogre now."